so this is a new segment called crazy
ass stories and this guy dm joe joe read
what this guy said to you uh which we're
going to allege that this is true we
have no way to verify it but it's a
crazy ass story so what did this guy say
to you outside of uh maybe oh no no read
a word for word
of course i said outside making fun of
me i i like to think that he's telling
the truth but but we'll see all right so
that was a good primer this guy made fun
of joe he's mad yeah well you'll see in
a second so i got a dm yesterday uh 2 30
in the afternoon it's from someone on
twitter we have concealed his name and
he was okay with us sharing this uh so
what he said was joe love the show love
the roku trash talk just wanted to slide
into your dms privately and tell you 10x
is baby [ __ ]
which all time damn credit on that he
literally went through the leg 360 bam
dunk done the best part was like when i
first read it i thought he was like like
doing me a favor he was like privately
like i came in private i want to do this
in public but like it's baby [ __ ] so so
he says that then he goes on a serious
note though i have a question for the
show nft trading got me 340xing right
now turned 40 into 216 000 with an
estimated balance of 591 000 if i
liquidated all my nfts today my question
for the show is how would you guys
approach quitting my steady 100 000
salary to produ to pursue a life in
crypto and nfts that i have more passion
for
and then yeah regardless if it makes a
show keep killing it
wait he also said wife has a good salary
at 135k yeah so this was the follow-up i
asked him for if there was any more info
he needed no he said my wife has a good
salary at 135 000
we have yearly expenses around 60 000
uh bonus question would be converting
fiat to crypto allocation right now i
have a 40-60 balance thoughts on
balancing this with respect to leaving a
steady salary so he wants to know he's
got potentially six hundred thousand
dollars in nfts his wife makes a hundred
and thirty five thousand dollars a year
he's thinking about leaving a hundred
thousand dollar job what should he do
should he do it how should he allocate
can we go back to the first message
before we address the answers i wanna
call out two things first of all this
guy told you 10x is baby [ __ ]
we're not going to let that just slide
on by 10x is baby [ __ ] he basically said
screw his brokenness he didn't put the
other one up there but there was a
message in between where he says he gets
to five x daily
he said all right okay okay the second
thing i was gonna call out is he just
casually threw in there i have a
question for the show nft trading got me
340x most people be like oh i like
doubled my money at 2x did i 10x to no
one's like i got 54 xing you know on a
daily basis this guy said 340x seeing
like that's a round number that people
are used to using so he's got 340 eggs
bro he said he turned 40
into 216 000
i don't think that's 340x either
right
let's see
to 216
000. 300 and what do you say 340 no no
no he he said
he said turn 40 into 216 okay
what is that 340
yeah that would be 340x would be 13 600.
so what is 216 000 divided by 40.
some people say damn greatest 5 400.
maybe he was 5 400. all right so he's 5
400 x'ing out here uh but
what it appears to be in the second
message is that his wife has a great job
and if she's making 135 000 a year let's
say that they pay we'll just use these
numbers 50
taxes
if they do that that then i'm not a
genius here but that would be what
67.5 k
a year is that right no public math i
don't do public math but what calculator
boys what is 135 divided by two it's 67
points calculated after that ooh johnny
don't touch it all right 67.5 oh look at
that big boy brain right there all right
67 point divided something by two
the seventh grader we just talked about
does that in his sleep
oh he got all that ooh i i'm just my bad
my bad guys i got him upset
135 is a hard number to divide by two i
had to go into the decimal places
to get the accurate number
thank you
which was the seventh graders learning
right now
uh so
if they make
67.5 k
after taxes from just her salary and
yearly expenses are 60k
you could live after taxes completely on
your wife's salary if she likes her job
and she's cool with you taking risk
eject let's go
let's go
right
i'm sure they have savings he already
has a ton of money in this stuff there
is a very good chance very important
there's a very good chance that a lot of
it is highly inflated in price yeah so
what you should do again not financial
advice terms and conditions talk to your
lawyer talk to your accountant talk to
john whoever you want uh
it's john's smirking right now because
he's like yeah yeah i'm in there talk to
me i'm gonna tell you to quit your job
is i would take some of what is in that
balance i would convert it to either
fiat or bitcoin right which is seen as
the more conservative asset in the
industry and then if you think you got
an edge here i don't have an edge in
this but if you think you got an edge go
for it especially if you're like a
younger dude go for it you got your
yearly expenses covered by your wife and
her salary then you've got savings
and you've got a little bit of fiat cash
and then you've got some of the nft
balance
and go for it if you could if you could
grab
three four five million dollars by the
end of the year change your life because
you got an edge doing something and it's
not illegal it's not unethical and
you're not uh taking advantage of people
let's go yeah so you're gonna get rich
sitting at your shitty job that you
obviously want to leave but you're too
scared to do it so you're dm and my
brother on the internet asking them i
got two things all right or three things
i guess uh
one would be that you actually need to
figure out how much all this stuff is
worth right like you said some of this
is uh the actual prices depending on
kind of the nfts in the marketplace and
stuff like this
say that they're worth a little more
than you could actually liquidate it for
and the price could change and all the
stuff so yeah you need to have at least
a general understanding usually it's
typically better to uh underestimate
that stuff so say you know maybe if you
think it's here actually think that it's
here and put that on paper that's one
thing two uh would be that you need to
have a plan right you don't want to want
to just quit and say hey i'm gonna go
trade nfts and i'm gonna go buy and sell
these things and try to make cash you
need to have a plan of what you're gonna
do with the cash where you're gonna put
it what kind of return you're gonna get
how you're going to live off that where
you're going to budget what your
expenses are going to be all the stuff
right so the wife's salary is part of
that but then when he personally wants
to leave his job you need to have a plan
of what you're going to do three
from from a personal standpoint i think
it's probably uh you want to make sure
your wife's cool with you chilling on
message boards all day long when she
works to cover expenses there might be a
uh a conflict there but outside of that
everything's probably good john what do
you think
yeah i agree with everything joe said um
damn just a hundred percent 100 percent
someone said i'm hating in the comments
i ain't hating he should do it that's
what he wants to do i said you should
have a plan yeah you should have a plan
john
let john speak no you should have a plan
i i agree with it look it's
unfortunately you probably won't get
rich
working for someone else and making them
rich so if you want to go do something
and you like you said you have that
competitive edge in it uh go do it if
you like doing it that's also very
important so
look it all depends on what you're
optimizing for and sounds like this
guy's optimizing for cash um so just go
for it why not the other thing that i
think is important here is uh one
we talk about bitcoin a lot that i think
in most people's eyes is seen as the
most conservative thing in this industry
nfts are on the other end of the
spectrum
they've gone up a lot appreciate it
they're very hard to value in terms of
any sort of fundamental analysis etc
three is we don't have a ton of
historical data to know how these
perform
and then four and probably most
importantly is um
there is a chance that as
the demand for it increased so much
supply lagged as supply lagged all of a
sudden the demand got more and more more
and more because it was driving price up
right so if you think about if there's a
hundred nfts there and there's only five
buyers at first they're normal prices
then all of a sudden we go to now
there's a thousand people that want
those hundred nfts what happens prices
start to go up then all of a sudden it's
not a thousand people who want 100 nfts
now there's 120 nfts but there's 10 000
people that want them price even goes up
faster which brings in more people on
the demand side so you've seen this
massive increase in the demand side the
supply has a lag to it and so as that
supply starts to come online it would
not surprise me at some point to see the
supply actually outpace the demand you
can't grow demand forever and you can
grow supply forever people will keep
kind of feeding the ducks if they're
quacking and so as you see that occur
there will be a point where prices cool
off or crash you just got to understand
two things one what's your risk
management strategy and then two is what
is your long-term strategy or plan to
joe's point and so if you want to go do
this stuff you think you've got to edge
doing it knock yourself out but also
understand that it's kind of like when
you're at a casino and you're literally
playing blackjack if you just leave all
the chips on the table the whole time as
you're winning then you're gonna leave
with either zero
or a ton there's no in between but if
you're intelligent as you're winning
what do you do you take some of the
chips off put them in your pocket you
play with what's on the table and if you
end up losing then you're done but
you're walking away with some chips
actually in your pocket and that's the
key to a lot of this is you have to have
the risk management and take profits
along the way because nothing goes up
forever and so i think the other piece
of it is uh that we've got to understand
um how
we've got to understand how the
uh market ends up working here of
if he just stays in nfts it ends up
actually being pretty risky because
you're betting on a sector that is
unlikely to stay going up forever
instead if he's able to diversify
whether it's in this industry or into
fiat as well then he's actually going to
be at a pretty good financial position
hey guys bang bang thanks so much for
watching the best business show today
and don't forget to check out our
partner sofi they make all this possible
they're a super app that lets you save
spend borrow earn and invest all from
one single platform and if you go there
today and you sign up for a sofi invest
account you can get between five dollars
and a thousand bucks for free from sofa
not everyone's obviously gonna get a
thousand dollars but everyone gets
something don't say that i never did
anything for you go check them out at
sofi.compomp
download the app and go ahead and open
an account
sofi.compomp and make sure you come back
and watch more of the best business show
we're going to build the biggest
business show in the world and we need
your help
[Music]